the leia hope and show sponsored by step
finance your go to d5 portfolio manager
on solana luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to another episode of
the leia hill pan show powered by the vc firm
icon plus capital as usual this is also sponsored
by block fight so check out block by um you can
actually get amazing interest rates i think
right now on stable coins it's around 9 which
could be the most competitive so i've actually
left the link for you in the description and in
the comment section i use them i like them so
definitely go check them out so today is going
to be a little interesting actually um because i'm
speaking with somebody that i don't know that well
usually this doesn't happen uh so i'm quite
excited and it's going to be very um nft based
so our nfts are bubble um i think it's pretty
hot right now so i'm excited to to chat with him
so he's sort of come out of nowhere in the last
eight months um he's a big youtuber um he's
built a huge community and he's sort of known as a
little bit of a nft expert says bring him in it is
matt's crypto hey matt how you doing how's it
going thanks for having me on i'm good how you
doing how you doing i'm great i can't complain
with nfts right now things are going pretty well
yeah i'm really excited to chat with you because
like i said we don't know each other that well so
this is just going to be learning about each other
understanding the nft space um but before we go
into the nft space i want to know a bit about
you because you sort of popped out of nowhere
in the last eight months on youtube you've built
an amazing an amazingly engaged audience like it's
pretty crazy so talk to me about that where did
you come from uh well i mean i guess for people
that are you know in the crypto space yes i
did pop up eight months ago but i i've been
on youtube for uh 12 years actually so this is not
my first rodeo when it comes to youtube channels
so that's that's probably in part why the channel
is doing so well i have i have an idea of how to
make a youtube channel work but um yeah
so like two years ago i got into crypto
um one of my buddies runs a a mining company in
north america one of the biggest ones actually um
and he's been you know i was living with him for
five years throughout college and uh so i started
to get more interested in it one thing led to
another uh started getting into all coins and then
naturally progressed to nfts and and here we are
made a channel about it and it's doing quite well
so i actually didn't know that you'd um i mean
i could see now in the background but i didn't
know all of this um about your background so tell
me what other youtube channels have you built and
i want the full story um that's i've probably done
over a dozen channels in in the last 12 years um
there's a lot of my main one was a gaming
channel a lot of call of duty uh you know
shooters first person shooters um and then i've
done like trending channels like top 10 channels
i've done animation channels um i've kind of done
a little bit of everything and then i also consult
for other channels um all different kinds a lot of
gaming uh some animation but you know a bunch of
different youtube channels so i have a pretty good
understanding of how youtube and um you know how
to grow how to grow a channel you know organically
um but yeah that's that's pretty much it
i think everyone wants to know how to grow a
channel organically like what are your number one
tips tell me i need to grow what are your number
one um well i actually asked you before we started
the show why do you prefer to do these live uh
because yeah i think i actually think they would
do a lot better if you did them as standalone
videos even though we recorded you know we
pre-record it live yeah i think it will do better
if you if you actually edited out the best parts
and um you know added some graphics and stuff
like that i think we do actually a lot better
okay we'll have to talk about that after
the show yeah i just i like doing it live
i like it it just feels natural it's fun it's
a lot it's a lot more fun it's definitely uh
a little bit easier to do from a you know creator
perspective like it takes a lot less time right
um and you have like a great looking show here
so it looks good either way for your end but
i i do think you'll see noticeable difference in
the view numbers if you um do it the other way oh
my gosh maybe i will all right oh somebody just
said ouch don't hurt her like that not at all i
love this this is good okay so pre-recorded
is better than live this is good to know so
is this your full-time this is your full-time
job right crypto youtube so yeah i would say
at the moment i have three full-time jobs um
my brother and i run a production company uh
that's done very well in the last two three years
and then i started the youtube channel because we
also you know we consult with other youtubers
that's part of like the production company gig
um but one thing led to another and now this
channel's you know existed and it's doing quite
well so i've basically taken most of my time away
from the production company while he's continue to
run that i'm doing the youtube channel full time
um i have a private membership on patreon and then
we also just launched a nft platform it's not like
a marketplace like openc or anything but it's it's
a platform that helps you find identify and and
purchase uh good nfc deals i see okay so before
we delve into all the nft stuff um you said you
got into the old coin market was it two years ago
uh yeah i would say yeah about so how did
you get in like what do you like about crypto
i mean what i don't like about crypto um
i feel like you've done a really good job
articulating all this stuff throughout you know
fox cnbc all of your channel but it's it's what
everyone else says right it's uh it's protecting
you against burning your money with with inflation
um that's probably the first and foremost
thing i also love the technology behind it
um i think one of the things that i like the most
about the content part of it is that it involves
technology innovation which is something that
i've always found really fascinating um never
really done it on youtube but i've always wanted
to do something in a technology and finance realm
and so this is like a perfect opportunity to mix
content creation finance technology all together
i don't know i mean i obviously like
when it goes up like everyone else um
but i just think it's uh it's a great technology
i think it's inevitable that it's the future
um and this is not just bitcoin this is you
know multiple different cryptocurrencies but
uh yeah i mean there's there's a lot to say about
it but it's great yeah no i hear you um but you do
focus a lot um on nfts so let's let's go into
this where's where do you see value in nfts
i i think it's still so early that people are
having a hard time grasping where the value is
going to be and i don't think anyone really knows
where the where it's going to end up i think the
best example i can give because i've done gaming
is if you have played fortnite and most people
watching have probably played fortnite at
least once or understand what fortnite is
in the game it's free to play right so anyone
can play in the world which is great but in the
game there are skins like character skins you can
play as and this is huge i mean they've had marble
characters they've had um all different kinds of
like really popular pop culture characters in the
game so people will buy those skins and usually
they're fifteen dollars twenty dollars and they
go through they go through v bucks but really
it's twenty dollars and i've bought personally
myself probably 2 000 worth of skins in this
game wow if you just had those skins as nfts
you'd be able to own those skins and then for
example when i don't play the game anymore like
now i don't play the game anymore those skins are
worthless now i spent 2 000 and i never get back
they're in the game and they exist but epic games
really owns those scans can you not sell it can
you you you bought it you bought it though right
but you can't sell it nope so i basically spent 2
000 on skins and some of them are very rare like
really early on like i was playing this thing
before many people were because that's the scene i
was in uh and they've gone up in value right well
they you no one knows because there is no value on
them you can't resell them you can't really trade
them so no one really knows what the value is
but i'm saying if these were all nfts for example
i would own them and i would be able to resell
them on the marketplace at any time to anyone and
some of them being as rare as they are i imagine
would be worth several thousand dollars at this
point because people really want those scans
and the only way you can get them is if you
play the game super early on for some of them so
that's like the easy example i can give for for a
number one use case uh that's in gaming that's
one area i think it's going to be applied to
to our to uh all different kinds of areas in
in any kind of niche that you're interested in
i think there's use cases for nfts in in many
different ways another one is coachella is a
music festival that's out here by us and they just
came out with their own nft collection called the
infinity keys and it's basically a key as an nft
right a digital asset that allows you access to
go to coachella every year for life for a lifetime
you and another guest can go every single year for
life if you do the numbers every year if you pay
for tickets they're 500 a year um and right you
see you pay for the ticket you go to the event
you have your fun and that's it it's over with
the nft you can do the same thing you pay for
the nft go to the event come home and you still
own the nft so you can go again for the next 10
years if you want to or you could sell the nft at
any time and kind of get some that money back and
potentially even get more money than you put in
so i think like nfts have a ton of use cases
and there's no way we'd cover them all even in
even in the hour we have um but those are
like two examples that i think are kind of
somewhat easier for for most people to understand
like this is this is the obvious use case behind
the technology um and it
turns like liabilities and and
one-time purchases into potentially
investments and assets for the long term
so i struggle with nfts um i'm not against them
at all like i'm all for it you know let's innovate
let's make everybody's lives better let's take
ownership um so i understand the whole in-game
asset thing for me that works i get that right
i'm also just not a gamer like it's just not in
my it's not in my bones at all like the reason i'm
here comes from a much more political standpoint
which a lot of my um audience know in terms of
like freedom and all that stuff um so the gaming
thing i get but it doesn't apply to me okay
um but then like the thing with the tickets
you go to a concert right and i understand
super bowl the super bowl are doing nft tickets
you go to a concert um and then i just throw away
my ticket what you just described with coachella
sounds like a season ticket right with like you
would do a football match that we have at home
so you know you have a season ticket you pay x
amount so that would cover x amount of seasons
however many years um but like i don't i don't get
the trading like i don't get why would you make it
into an nft i just why would you make a ticket
into an nft it sounds like um a gimmick rather
than a real value okay for the coachella example
since you brought that one up coachella sells the
ticket to me right yeah the regular ticket uh like
a like you know one time this this year i'm going
for 500 kind of general admission if i can't go
for some reason let's say i get sick or i just
don't want to go i could resell that ticket on
like stubhub or ebay or something like that yes
what happens then is i i sell it on step up and
i pay an outrageous amount of fees let's just say
it's a hundred dollars worth of fees so one fifth
of the cost of the ticket is now gone right so now
i basically paid i i only got 400 even though
i paid 500 so i lost 100 and i didn't get to go
stubhub makes that money and then when they
sell it they also get a seller fee when the
person that buys it from me they take a fee on
that end as well so that person also pays more
than if i'm selling it at the same price of 500
they pay let's say five 580 or five you know 590
or whatever so stubhub makes the money both times
there coachella gets nothing out of it if it was
an nft not the lifetime nft just a regular nft
pass i have the nft that i bought from coachella
same way as the ticket but then when i go and
sell it to anyone else coachella gets those
royalty fees and they can set that royalty rate as
whatever they want they could be five percent 10
right and that's still ten percent is on the high
end of what things are right now and that's still
less than the stubhub fees who decides exactly
who decides that ten percent coachella does or
the creator in this in this case it's coachella
but it could be whoever creates the nft right
it doesn't have to be just hotel it could be i
think i've created my own entities anyone can
create their own fts uh you know an artist a
celebrity whatever so you create those royalty
fees and then if i sell it to someone else
coachella gets that royalty fee from the sale
and then if that person also can't go
and they want to sell to someone else
coachella gets the rotif again and the best
part is because it's all on the blockchain
it's super easy to do it's all digital we can
do it from anywhere in the world so someone
across the world like you know in the
uk for example wanted to go to coachella
they could buy the ticket you know anywhere
in the world same way step up i guess in a
way but if there's a physical ticket behind it
i have to actually ship it to them which costs
money and then stub ups got to verify that i
didn't counterfeit that ticket you know it's a
legitimate ticket all that gets wiped away easier
to do all verified by the blockchain it's cheaper
for people and the creator actually gets to see
that royalty so they're okay with people reselling
reselling reselling because they're going to
keep getting a kickback on that sale no matter
what the price is no matter how many times we sold
so when you because i've i've never minted an nft
um and so you're saying that if i submit
an nft on like open c variable whatever it
is you're saying that i can actually choose the
percentage of royalties and i will always get paid
well okay so there's two if you're creating
an nft like your own collection that you've
you know you've put together whether it's
r or whatever um you create the royalty fee
and you can put that in on openc on looks
rare wearable wherever uh when you min minting
technically you can mince your own stuff right but
a lot of times what will happen is i'll put on a
sale right a public sale and then other people
will mint those nfts and when they mint them um
it's variable depends on if it's like a you
know an art project or if it's they're all if
they're all the same then it's not really that
important if they're if it's in our project
where they're each different and you want to have
rarities it's important to have transparency that
your your items are rare and you're not like
hand selecting and favoriting who gets what
so that way you know a mint uh where you're
bringing something into existence essentially
bringing that nft into existence uh it's important
that it's it's done as a mint and not just a
you know a transaction where i've already minted
them as a creator and then you're just buying it
off of me it's important that you mint it so
that we can have it uh randomly generate which
one you get right and then another thing which
like stumbles me about what you say as well is
is the gas fees on ethereum so like yeah somebody
somebody so i i have i have nfts i've never minted
one um and one of the nfts is is now worth
like 3 8 or something like that and i wanted
to counter it but to counter it it cost me money
somebody put put like uh an offering of like three
i wanted to counter it and to counter it cost
me like 200 um which is wild yeah so i'm like
i'm gonna i'm not gonna counter i'm just gonna
wait until i get a price that i'm happy with and
then obviously pay the 200 to sell it especially
if it's like three fourth it doesn't matter so
okay gas is a fun explanation because it's very
confusing uh so i understand your frustration i
mean when i first when i first got into it there
was a a project called only force that i was going
to mint a bunch of them uh and i didn't because
the gas price was more than the cost of the nft
the gas was like 400 and then fc was like 200. so
i was like that's that's ridiculous i'm not going
to pay more in a fee than the thing costs itself
turns out two weeks later those were worth like
forty thousand dollars so i really should have
done it but yeah the gas fees are a little bit
interesting it the the price of gas changes
constantly i mean i'm not sure how familiar
with how uh yeah gas works on ethereum you do know
yeah okay so i mean what you really want to do
go through it go through in case anyone watching
doesn't know yeah so so basically every you know
every few seconds the price of gas will
change and that can range anywhere from
i've seen as low as like 20 grey all the
way up to 2 000 3 000 gray which is insane
uh and glaze is just a denomination a very
small fraction of an ethereum so it helps you
you know and instead of point zero zero
zero one it's a hundred way for example um
so that changes constantly and that basically
changes based on how many people are using
the network at a given time so if people are
sending a lot of money back and forth or people
are augmenting an nft uh you know the traffic
on the network goes up and then the miners will
charge you more to get your transaction to go
through quick what you want to do when you're
in nfts uh if you're minting something and
there's a bunch of people minting it it's usually
unavoidable that gas is going to go high and they
call it gas wars because you basically have to bid
higher gas amounts to get your transaction to
go through to be able to get part of that mint
before it sells out um what happens recently
is that most products are doing white lists
so they're basically hand picking people to
put on a pre-sale list so that you can mint
at any time you want within a certain window and
that way people aren't competing with gas to get
their transaction to go through you basically
have time whether it's six hours 24 hours to
find a time when it's convenient for you and
when gas is lower and then you can mint yours
at a lower price you know a lower gas fee so
the projects are are helping the communities
save money and gas by not fighting against each
other to get into that project the only thing
there is that you usually have to grind and spend
a lot of time to get on those white lists because
they hand select who they get in and they
usually want the community to be loyal and
interested in the project and to showcase
that you have to kind of show that you're
you know active and involved in what they're doing
so it's it's kind of a trade-off you can instead
of paying money on gas you're paying your time to
show the project that you're worth being on the
pre-sale list that's kind of where it's gone at
the moment but uh if you're not minting generally
speaking i usually try to find time like if you
want to buy something or if you want to sell
something and list something i find a time when
gas is lower um it's completely variable sometimes
there are certain days that are a little bit
better and times of the day that are a little bit
better when a lot of people are asleep obviously
that's usually a good time to try to do it and
i would say generally speaking right now anything
below 100 gwei is i would i want to say it's cheap
but it's it's it's better than it's been six
months ago 100 gray was outrageously expensive
but now it's it's i i i infrequently find it where
it's below 100. if it's below 100 i'm like okay
i'm going to do some transactions i'm going to do
some trades because it doesn't doesn't go below
100 much right now it's very the scene's extremely
hot yeah and which brings me to my next topic um
what about competitors right so how do you feel
about solana versus ethereum like i'm i like
just before you go into it for me personally i
like the idea that solana is of course cheaper
um but then i am concerned about like the network
switches on and off again and decentralization and
for me that's just kind of bizarre yeah i mean
no matter what what platform we're talking about
there's always going to be trade trade-offs right
some are better at certain things some are better
than others solana definitely is cheaper uh there
are really no gas wars the thing i would say that
i've noticed in my time in you know solana nitis
particularly is that there are a lot of bots uh
that can just force mints and you can't i mean if
you're an average person uh you like myself even
like you really can't compete with a bot you just
can't um so that's that's one downside i would say
i also think that the scene at least at the
moment is much more uh there's a lot more
people on ethereum trading ethereum entities so
i would say that if you're looking for you know
some crazy you know crazy investments or things
that are really going to blow up or things that
really have a lot of potential i haven't seen
any solana projects recently that have done
insane are anywhere near the numbers that
ethereum entities would do uh that's not
to say that it won't i definitely think honestly
but why is that i just is it fast mover advantage
partially and i just think that i mean a lot
of the projects even even for me examples we
we launched our own nft and we had a choice you
know we could do solana we could do ethereum we
could do cardano if we really wanted to um it's
just the most most users are on ethereum and
i think it's really important for a
project right now to have that demand
in order to you know reach as many people
as you can uh and so that's you know that's
where a lot of people are choosing to go as
ethereum even though there are still obvious um
i don't know just where it's at right now i mean
if you look at the numbers the biggest platform
is openc and they just passed a million users and
this is not even active active users is like maybe
half of that maybe like 500 000 people total users
all time that have made just one transaction on
the platform is just past a million so in the
grand scheme of things like that's a and it's
a very small number of people that are actually
doing this and and playing with it right now so
you kind of need to reach those people yeah i
mean so this is like the way i look at it i think
ethereum right now is ahead of the game simply
because it's got that first mover advantage but
if we want to continue at this rate with mass
adoption because i think nfts have really been
the only thing which has brought like the average
person in right um i think that's sort of the oh
i think it's very unique in that sense but i just
don't think the average person is going to want to
stay on ethereum it's just too expensive um so i
wonder what that means for other blockchains even
like cardano i i honestly hope that there are
other competitors that make it uh that make a
push for it because anytime you have competition
it just kind of forces innovation to be quicker
i think whenever ethereum actually does upgrade to
2.0 i i hope and pray that the gas issue is less
of an issue or not an issue at all but you know
how long can we hold our breath for i don't know
i don't know i don't know um but let's talk about
like where the value comes from because i often
find that quite difficult like okay the whole
board ape yacht club it goes over my head like i'm
here to talk about it but i just i wouldn't pay
for it i i just wouldn't buy it buy one so talk
to me about where that value comes from well i
mean for board apes i don't know what the current
price is but the last time i checked it was around
100 ethereum so somewhere around 300 000 per per
ape which is just i mean obviously that's that's
outrageous for most people to pay um i i think
to be honest with you this is i i think most
people won't say it this way people that are
you know and i'm pro i'm pro nfts all the way
obviously but i think the truth of the matter
is right now people that are in the space that
are in it so heavily are here to make money
uh that's the truth i mean there are tons of
benefits as far as the technology being verifiable
and you know there's collectors and there's really
cool projects that offer access to certain groups
and certain utilities but the truth of the matter
is right now i think most people that are in it
are in it to make money ultimately whether
that's buying something like a board ape and
holding it for several years until it goes up
until you know who knows what price uh or just
flipping things quickly i think there are a lot
of flippers in the space right now because it is
a seller's market to be honest there's a lot of
demand coming in even though there's not a lot
of people there's a lot of money um so i think
a lot of people are trying to make their money
you know while they can uh while things are hot
so i mean for a lot of people that are getting
interested i would say that they're getting in
because they say oh my gosh you know my friend
told me about this nft that he bought and flipped
it for 20 grand in a week that's that's money that
you know it's it's no one else is making i'm
not making i don't think most people are making
in a week in any other job other than maybe a
celebrity professional assy athlete maybe uh so
i think that really draws people in and then once
they get in and they realize they can make money
great but they start to realize okay there are
also other things here that are valuable that i
didn't really understand until you get into it and
it's kind of hard to just lay it all out in one go
but like i said like there is access like
coachella um i don't know what those will
end up selling for but there's an argument
to be made that if you are a huge coachella
fan you buy one of those nfts instead of buying
the tickets and you can go each year there's also
some other perks that i didn't mention but
that add more value to it like you can have
10 of your friends do a private dinner at
coachella and a vip experience like there's little
things that are adding more value in that
case um but i think like there are a lot of
use cases for it that people actually will find
value in and they'll meet other people that are
in those communities that can provide further
value in different ways outside of crypto um
i mean there's there's so many things i can go
through right now but i think i think once you
get in you'll kind of understand more okay like
this is this is where their value where the value
actually lies so how do you navigate so like if i
wanted to start flipping nfts right because okay
people want to make money as you said how would
i know because the thing is at least like with
old coin projects right like you can understand
who the founders are what else they've built
you can look at the tokenomics um and then also
like you work in this space right so for me for
example somebody came to me with a project um
and i didn't really get the use case for it
um and then like we started talking about
other things and then i was like oh why
why doesn't this sort of exchange exist and they
were like well that's what they're building that's
what they're doing so but because i work in this
space i felt um i felt um like a what's the word
i felt like an open market for a specific thing
so i understood that okay that would actually
be really valuable because like the community
would need something like that with nfts like
how do you break that down okay so it's rare what
else right i think right now the rarity thing is
like is a big deal and i think it's not going
to be much longer i don't know how long it'll
last for but that's that's really not a good
way to i mean in certain circumstances sure
like think about a baseball card or a football
card or a pokemon card right like certain cards
are more rare i don't know if you're familiar but
like certain uh like generate like addition first
edition charizards are selling for outrageous
amounts of money right now first edition
you know yeah that's the one i had yeah yeah
exactly you get like so people people can
understand that to a degree i think there's
i mean there's still not a lot of people that
you know number wise that that would trade pokemon
cards still uh as like an actual investment avenue
right like maybe kids obviously like it's fun to
play with them and play the game and like collect
them and stuff like that but as an adult most
people would probably okay it's you know it's
a kids game but really like the the the rarity
and the um you know scarcity of those really rare
cards adds value to them and people are paying
you know the market has deemed them to be valuable
at this point those are 20 years old pokemon's one
of the biggest ip in the world so that obviously
adds a little bit of you know reason for more
value and in ways that maybe these nfts are
are so new it's like how can you really say that
that's valuable when it's so brand new um but the
truth is like they're very similar in that way as
far as for board a for example right at this point
there are more utilities behind it like access to
this community and access these uh people in it
that you wouldn't get if you're not in the group
but at the start it's just a picture of a monkey
it's a profile picture collection really it's
just like you know art that some people think
are cool and some people think is like why is
this work why am i paying money for a picture
but you can if you compare that and the rarity of
those certain things right especially now because
there's such a staple part like staple nft in
the whole space compare them to pokemon cards
the most rare board apes have actually more value
than the most rare pokemon cards and i think wait
let me just internalize that wait pause that
say that again the most what the most rare board
apes are the most expensive board apes are more
expensive than the most expensive pokemon cards
right right right at least at what the purchase
price has been this is like this is not my opinion
this is this is market value right this is
objective uh like this is what people have
paid so i don't believe this i haven't paid that
much but someone else has multiple people have so
the market currently values board ape nfts more
than pokemon cards i don't think that'll last
for for eternity i think it's gonna you know
ebb and flow because it's so new but the point
is that's where we're at right now uh and so the
the difference between pokemon cards and and board
apes is that nfts are so much easier to transact
and verify than traditional sports trading cards
if i wanted to buy a charizard i'd have to go to
someone that has it in person yeah that person
might live 20 minutes away they might live 2 000
miles away or you know across the world like and
to go and buy that they do they have to ship it to
me which they're never gonna do because it's such
an about a valuable asset i'd have to go there see
that it's legitimate verify that it's real buy it
you know probably have someone that can verify it
with me because i don't know enough to verify that
it's legitimate and then purchase that in person
somehow or maybe we you know do a bank transfer
like there's this is there's a whole ordeal if i
want to buy a board ape i go on my computer right
now click buy send the ethereum takes 45 seconds
and there we go i own the board eight and i don't
have to worry about it being fake or not because
i can verify that it's real on the blockchain
the the difference in they're the same like
they're very similar in what they offer as like
you know core value which is scarcity for this
example yes but one is so much easier to transact
and verify than the other not only that uh the
person that made board ape you know the founders
of the group every time they're bought and sold
they get that royalty commission so they're
making money constantly every time someone
sells so they have every incentive to make
sure their product does as well as possible
because they're going to get kickbacks from
every sale so everyone's incentivized in a way
to use the technology because it's just it's
the same thing we've had in some ways but it's
so much better than those old traditional ways
i still think that it's niche i still think
that it's niche um yeah there's like this
idea that everybody's in and you know but i i
don't think so i just think that like it's a
craze right now for people to make money right
so everybody's actually going to jump onto it
um but i think once the bubble dies down um
it will become something niche like i don't
i've never i don't collect things right what
i do is hold my crypto hold my bitcoin i don't
hold anything else like i don't trade cards yeah
i don't trade cards it's much easier you know like
yeah literally so you know i don't trade any
of those things like i can't and i don't play
those kind of games so like i can't relate um i'm
not an artist so for me i just i feel kind of like
i don't say ostracized that's not the right word
but i just feel that it's just not for someone
like me i think you are highlighting the point
that most people are in right now um by no means
am i saying like this is this is it's perfect it's
there's a ton of problems still like there's a lot
of things that are wrong with it still like i
said my first point on why things have value
my opinion is that people think they can make
money on it that's just the truth of the matter
most people in the scene i would argue are here
to make money at the moment but i also see that
there are so many use cases that are that are
really early on that haven't been figured out
the best way to do them yet and haven't been
you know onboarding people and making it easy
for people to understand and purchase is not there
yet by any means we are so so early in this space
uh i i my best comparison would be we
are crypto in 2014 maybe maybe 2013
uh were the internet in 1990s like it's early
it's super super super early uh and that's
why there's a lot of problems and that's why
people are able to make money so quickly because
someone's winning big and someone's losing big uh
and the thing that's drawing a lot of people in
i think it's not a lot of people it's maybe you
know several thousand people is that people are
seeing you can make a lot of money quickly
and who doesn't want to make money quickly
uh at some point that will change that narrative
i think will change where things like you know the
the foot about environmental issues and scams um
those things will be improved like any technology
has like i mean any new technology that comes out
always has issues to start uh until you know until
they get ironed out and it gets better so i think
it's so early that you know these things exist
and people here to make money but
at some point the use cases behind
the technology will come to the forefront and the
mainstream will understand like this is actually
great technology this is really helpful for
whatever i'm doing personally that i care about
and at some point that will that will take over
closure i think i'm just going to address some
of the comments because i'm reading through some
of the comments a lot of live comments which is
cool um so some people don't think this is live so
i'd like to confirm that this is 110 live which is
live we hadn't had a chat beforehand we just we've
literally just met now so this is very natural um
somebody asked if i hold any nfts um i hold two
nfts one somebody actually sent me yesterday um
and it's not a famous painter but i can't
remember it's actually a painting that
i have that i've grown up with in my house
and somebody turns into an nft which is cool
and then i hold um boss beauties which is
the one somebody sent me um which is now
worth like two point something eth um but the
funny thing is it's like i don't wanna sell it
that's what's messed up why don't you want to
show it i don't know i just i i don't know i
okay so i sort of feel like it's like the fomo
at the same time because it's kind of just
well you know what if it what if it becomes
a board ape huh like i want i want that 70
each kind of vibe like what if this will cause
a warning you know yeah no yeah that i i think
you have a similar uh mindset when it comes to
crypto investments that i do i i have bought
and bought and bought and bought and i haven't
sold anything ever and i could have you know i'm
like oh no wait wait wait wait wait you've never
sold anything no well and then it's easy yes but
not in crypto you've never sold any crypto no
what do you what are you holding if i may ask
so much uh largest is now ethereum it was
bitcoin for a while but now it's ethereum so
bitcoin ethereum cardano uh solana i hold a lot of
actually i hold a lot of luna i don't know if you
are a lunafan know about luna yeah i know about
luna um i i heard it i heard it's very good the
tokidomix is what i've heard it's very good one
the stable coin it burns every time you use it and
yeah that yeah i'm on the on the train that
uh at some point usdt and maybe even uh usdc
will not be accepted as much as they are now
because they're centralized entities and if
people really believe in the decentralization
of stable coins that us terra is one of the
options that may take over so for that reason
i'm i'm a big believer in luna um another one
that that's much like a really really really
small altcoin is is omi um omi omi yeah and it's
the the cryptocurrency behind vv which is a
nft platform that is much more geared towards
um it's i think it's a lot easier to get into as
a platform than the mainstream ethereum type stuff
so you guys can check that out if you want to i'm
not going to give you a whole rant on it but i'm
a big believer in that as well they have disney
and marvel ip on that with their nfts because
they've actually licensed it from those
companies so i think those will be huge
at some point um and then probably like 15
other altcoins wow and you've never sold one no
well i mean i did sell some at a loss for tax
purposes but okay uh like very very small amounts
that's wild that's absolutely crazy um let's talk
let's talk mass adoption um how do you how do you
see things going from here right so like it's kind
of unclear what kind of market we're in i'd still
say we're in a bull market certainly um nfts are
still booming um nfts have been i think a great
form of mass adoption one of the best forms we've
ever seen um there's also like a lot of regulation
coming the us is quite hostile right now so
how do you see this space developing from here
for nfts or for crypto or both both yeah both you
can start with nfts um well i mean one thing i've
actually noticed is that when crypto does well
nfts the volume gets dried up i see people are
going back and forth um so truthfully my one
of my strategies right now is to start playing
into that because i've seen it twice happened
twice now pretty well correlated both times when
crypto runs uh nfts start to the floor start to
dwindle quickly and that's usually i mean from
historically i've seen it's a good good time
to buy in potentially and then vice versa when
you know when nfts are hot is when crypto is like
when crypto had that decline from november to now
i guess roughly uh that's nfts have been on the
up and up and then like really peaked i would say
like two weeks ago and you can see that on google
trends you can see that on floor prices across the
market like it's correlated quite well now that
eath and bitcoin are starting to move again a
little bit i'm seeing some floors drop pretty
drastically on nft so um i think they're like
inversely correlated so i'm gonna try to play into
that a little bit but overall i i i have a lot of
opium with with crypto so it's like i i want us to
believe in a bull market uh i was a firm believer
in a lot of people that i watch that the end of
2021 would be similar to the 2017 uh blow off
top where we had like a really big run and a peak
obviously that did not happen uh or maybe it did
if you think that you know 64 000 or maybe 69 000
was the peak then maybe it did happen already i
don't think that's the peak i think we still have
more room to run as far as the build market goes
but because i've gotten so ingrained in nfts my
day-to-day like worry and care and looking at the
prices of all other crypto has gone to like zero
i kind of just check in every once in a while to
see like if there are major movements for for
what i might expect to happen in nfts but i'm
playing the nft game right now and like i said i
haven't sold anything in crypto so my my plan is
just told that the technology the base case
the foundation the fundamentals behind all the
technology in my opinion hasn't changed whether
there's regulation that you know negatively
impacts it probably will happen at some point
uh i just think that where we're going is is
going to be far greater than any kind of timing i
can do right now so i'm just going to let it ride
and with nfc zen i know obviously you're bullish
on the whole idea of play to earn um trading cards
but once everything does die down um where do
you see where do you how do you see them being
adopted do you think you know it's going to be
music like what's the main use case going to be
just like just as a side point just to say it
sort of reminds me of twitter actually because
when twitter first came about it was like this
mainstream platform right it was like snapchat
facebook whatever it was now it's like really fun
and niche which is like in more like intellectual
news conversation you know it's not it's not tick
tock right it's for it's for a little it's for
an older crowd who want to have different types
of conversations so where do you see nfts going
um in turn okay just just in general i feel
like you prefaced it with twitter which is
an interesting uh comparison but yeah i i
mean i think i think what will happen is
if the crypto bull market does continue and
we do see like some crazy run um and it you
know continues to be a cycle in some degree then i
think we're gonna see a really rough time in nfts
uh and maybe even if crypto doesn't run we'll
see that that period i just think i mean if
you compare it to any you know like bitcoin for
example after it goes crazy hot there's gonna
be a period where it comes back down and people
think it's just a fad people think it's just a
you know get get rich quick scheme or something
like that i think that still has to happen um
or on the flip side mainstream businesses find
a way to uh make it really easy for people to
get into nfts because it's not easy right now it's
very it's very time consuming it's very confusing
there's way too many moving parts there's way too
many uh abilities for people to get scammed and
there's there's a lot to it right now so i don't
think it's it's easily ready for mainstream
adoption that has to happen whether that happens
soon or not i don't know uh it really depends on
what you know like for example mastercard i think
or visa i think has teamed up with coinbase to try
to allow people to buy nfts with credit cards
which would be a huge on-ramp if they if they
paired with coinbase as well because it's publicly
traded i think that's a huge differentiator
between coinbase you know and their nft platform
they're coming out and something like openc
um i think people have a lot more trust in
coinbase than they do with these other you know
other up and coming platforms so if they pair with
a major credit card company to allow people to buy
nfts on ethereum through a credit card or debit
card that people already trust that would be a
huge uh catalyst for where things are going to
keep going and then maybe we won't see an nfc
bear market per se but if that doesn't happen i
really do think we're gonna have a period where
it's gonna get ugly most projects will go to
basically zero or you know stop uh stop doing
what they're doing because it's just you know
no one's using it anymore but at the same time
the ones that and we call them blue chips but it's
hard to say blue chip because it's only been like
eight months for most of these projects but the
blue chip projects i do think if you can buy them
at that you know that low that low in the in the
market i think people are going to make a fortune
if you can find the right ones and i don't know
what those are i'll be trying to figure it out but
yeah i mean that's just everything in this
market isn't it like that's just everything
with even if it's like with you know what's
the next meme coin what's the next yeah i
mean if you find it if you play it right you you
know you absolutely can make a lot of money but
you're gonna have a lot of failures in
trying to find the right one i'm sure
i i personally have i've tried a couple different
ones and i'm like you know what i'll just put a
little bit of money in there and who knows if
it goes crazy great if it goes to zero it goes
to zero like that's that's yeah i'm gonna take on
some small small small amounts yeah i think that's
what i always say i always say like the best thing
to do is never to okay obviously never afford more
you can afford to lose and actually but also um
it's not just that it's also like sometimes you're
gonna have to wait a while i feel this way about
bitcoin right like for me bitcoin will always
recover like i'm just like forever bullish
on bitcoin it always recovers you have to be
be able to afford patience like you have to be
able to financially afford patients and wait
um but yeah that's my thing with nfts
a lot of them will go to xero just like
many altcoin projects so i'm just very
hesitant and i think it's about finding
that value which i'm not 100 sure what it is long
term just yet i i don't know i don't know if i
have the answer either i think there are a lot of
i think there will be use cases for most niches
i just don't know what those will be yet like
what the the prevalent and and useful most useful
uh mass adopted ones will be i think play to
earn is an easy example that i think is already
somewhat obvious uh and that will be what what
is the biggest thing for gaming to start i think
there there are so many other things like there's
there there are uh guilds where you can own entity
assets that are playable in the games and then
rent those out to like esports organizations or
you know communities or players and that will
be a business in itself it's already happening
but i think that'll happen to me much like i think
esports organizations in the future will be that
that was what they'll be they'll be like they'll
own a bunch of really valuable in-game assets
that they allow their players or their community
to use or rent out and that's their business model
i think that's gonna happen i just go that
just like defeats the whole purpose though
right because then like you don't own it anymore
the company owns it which i think is like one
of the issues with with crypto because like we're
trying so hard to you know create decentralization
but then like these major companies come in these
you know these web three vc kind of companies come
in and start centralizing the whole damn thing
um which one right well so okay so i don't when
i say companies i mean i don't mean like the
game companies i mean like uh no companies
right companies though but that's that you
you they'll own it if they want to and they
can rent it to you if you want or you can buy it
yourself like you don't have to have yeah but what
if they buy it all up and then it's too difficult
well i mean they're not going to buy all of them
it's coming you know i really think so i
really i really do think so i think it's like
i think it's like a catch-22 like we fight so hard
to to um you know regain our you know sovereignty
over whatever the hell it is whether it's money
assets in-game assets but i i do think that they
will come in i mean i'm sort of seeing this slowly
i mean and that's why i know like a lot of bitcoin
is kind of uncomfortable with web3 because it's
not what it's supposed to be but we'll see we'll
see i just hope things can stay decentralized i've
seen i've seen the conversation a couple times uh
i i will say we'll see what happens i don't
personally think that well i mean it will be an
issue to some degree like they will definitely own
a good stake in the in the game per se but there's
no way that they're going to own or be able to
afford to own everything uh if that does happen i
imagine that the market will find a way to
make it so that it's not you know that it's
not basically what we're trying to fight against
which is which is centralization and you know
monopoly essentially uh of the space i just don't
think that will happen but like i know i shouldn't
i know i shouldn't say this so i'll like whisper
it quietly um but like for example michael sailor
right um microstrategy buying up lots of bitcoin
imagine just imagine i'm not saying they are at
this point at all but like what happens if like
all these major institutions because they can
afford to end up buying up all the bitcoin right
and then the only way we can get more of a cut is
through like some form of bitcoin etf or some kind
of you know share and micro strategy and then you
don't actually own the actual bitcoin you just
own a share and a company that owns bitcoin like
grayscale bitcoin trust or whatever i don't know
i'm just i'm always i'm watching what's happening
um and yeah i mean uh the answer is don't sell
your bitcoin there you go that's your answer
or wait so long enough until they're they're you
know they make the market price and then you have
to ask for an unreasonable amount of money to
sell it yeah but that that obviously favors the
people that are in early and not the mainstream
that we are you know trying to potentially get
on board to understand like the benefits of
this right defeats the benefits if if if you
know if someone owns all of it or most of it i
agree with that yeah i just like get to be early
it is good to be early i just don't uh well i
don't know we'll see we'll see what happens i mean
you could be right that could be an issue i never
really thought about it that way but i just think
there'd have to be a lot i mean it had to be a
lot of people that are willing to sell to the same
handful of companies i guess yeah i don't know
i'll have to see how it plays out um it's weird
i i'm like i'm seeing how everything's going um
but like i'm i'm here for it i'm trying to learn
um you know i really appreciate um all the
nft content that you put out there because
i'm still trying to navigate it and i would
like to get more involved um somehow someway
so i'll figure that out um but matt where can
people find your content how can they follow you
uh so on youtube it's just matt's crypto just like
the name right down here there it is there it is
boom um yeah matt's crypto and then on on
twitter it's just matt cabuzio do you have any
um final thoughts that you want to say i'm uh i'm
excited uh i think regardless of you know the ebb
and flow and the ups and downs that's going to
happen no matter what uh i think crypto and nfts
have a long way to go and i obviously we're
both on the same boat that we think they're
going to go to a better place than they are now
a more mainstream place so i'm excited about it
uh i would just say you know if you are getting an
nfts uh obviously i have a bunch of content on my
channel you can watch but i would say also like do
your own research look at other people's channels
learn as much as you can what i tell all my
people in my private community is spend 15 hours
watching and participating as if you're
going to actually buy certain things
but don't actually buy anything yet so you can
kind of learn like hey this would have panned out
really well or i would have lost all of my money
because i was totally wrong about this idea that
i thought was gonna be really good and it wasn't
um i know from experience if you hop right in
you're gonna you're gonna make failures you're to
lose money it's going to happen so if you kind of
pretend like you're in and play the game a little
bit before you actually spend your money you'll
probably avoid a lot of those mistakes so just you
know try to learn about it i think i think if you
learn about it now this year at all you're going
to be so early you're going to thank yourself
later on that's what i think personally so yeah
i tend to take it yeah i tend to take a similar
opinion um but matt i want to thank you so much
for coming on it's been so great speaking with you
yeah i appreciate it thanks for having me
yeah for sure and guys thank you so much for
tuning in the comments have been really funny
i've been um watching them as as we've been
chatting so thank you guys so much for tuning
in um and i will see you all next week bye bye